Turns out vogelbaum made a kid born spring 1981.
Welcome back everyone this will be my full video
for the boys season three episode seven there
were so many easter eggs we have to talk about
they went full on empire strikes back star wars
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes they just
confirmed they're going to be filming season 4
really soon too so that means they'll probably be
able to release it by the end of next year careful
for spoilers for the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll be talking about everything just
starting at the beginning and we'll just go
through shot by shot talking about easter eggs and
wtf moments as we go along obviously the big thing
that everyone is talking about is them going full
on darth vader confirming a lot of our theories
like one of my biggest theories this season is
that they were going to say that soldier boy was
basically homelander's father like they used
his genetic material to create him in the lab
i am your father i suspected this might be the
case after early on during the interviews that
they were doing for the season they said that
soldier boy was meant to be the template for what
homelander eventually became and i was like what
if they actually made that a literal thing and not
just a metaphor one of my early theories before
season two was also they were going to say the
same thing about stormfront like they were gonna
have used some of her genetic material and she
would have been at least partly his biological
mother but the episode was titled here comes a
candle to light you to bed which is a reference to
the nursery rhyme here comes a candle to light you
to bed and here comes a chopper to chop off your
head which is like the worst nursery rhyme you've
probably ever heard it's meant to be a reference
to old school executions like an executioner is
coming to get you and it's meant to play in with
the whole idea of all this toxic masculinity
that's going around and what's happening with
soldier boy's character too like terrible people
being terrible fathers and then raising those
children to themselves become terrible people
when they become adults sort of playing in with
the idea of butcher like they kind of give you an
idea for what his backstory was in some of the
reason why he's so terrible in present day we
already knew a lot about homelanders backstory it
was the same thing with him like he had no father
they raised him like a test experiment and because
of that because he didn't get any of the nurture
or the love that he was supposed to get as a child
he just grew up to be this terrible person they'll
probably address this in the finale episode too
but the same thing plays in with the whole idea
of butcher and ryan like if butcher doesn't
become a better father or a better person
ryan is going to turn out just as bad as
homelander the actual opening scene is avat
addressing all the fallout from the end of last
week's episode was starlight's instagram post
just revealing everything that they've been doing
and everything about superheroes to the world the
funny thing is in real life the boys has a bunch
of social media accounts there's one for vought as
it vought is like a real company responding to all
these things happening on the show so after last
week's episode they posted basically what you see
happening during the scene here with vot trying to
throw starlight under the bus and the funny thing
that ashley does here during this broadcast she
tries to deflect attention from the actual truth
about superheroes and homelander doing the very
thing that she said that starlight is trying
to do to them deflect attention by telling
all these other lies about starlight like look at
all these crazy things she's doing and obviously
none of it's true but it's her deflecting
attention from what's really going on you have to
imagine now with the revelation about soldier boy
being homelander's father if they make that public
and they turn that into a big thing and use it for
good pr for homelander how quickly ashley is going
to talk to try and spin this to explain where he's
been this whole time and what really happened in
the past but isn't homelander so glad that he
didn't take victoria newman's advice to kill
soldier boy before he told tim the truth they
had this funny 80s commercial with soldier boy
on the legends tv all about not marrying an ugly
wife apparently and then just making fun of how
terrible a singer he is i'm sure jensen ackles had
fun doing all those fake ads it's kind of like the
fake ads that they have captain america do in
the marvel movies if you look around his room
he's got a payback poster above the fireplace it's
this poster here they posted on their social media
account you can also see a medieval themed sword
and shield which would have been an easter egg for
like the boys equivalent of a black knight type
of character and i love all the soldier boy jokes
about the stuff that he's getting up to while he's
just being super bored staying at ground trying to
hide out like do you have any more lube in the
whole joke that because he himself is like an
old man in a young man's body he really prefers
older women like really older women the legend
reveals that all of soldier boy's stories about
world war ii were fake he never lifted a finger
that is a minor change from the comics what
they've done is there's actually two different
versions of soldier boy one in the past and one in
present day they combined both of those and given
him a slightly different backstory in the comics
the original soldier boy did fight in world war ii
he was actually a teammate with mallories but he
was a terrible superhero he didn't know how to use
his powers and he basically got his entire squad
killed the way the legend explains it soldier
boy never saw any real action and they used him
more like they did at the beginning of the first
captain america movie like what if captain america
had just done what the military had asked him to
do and been more of a hype man for them selling
war bonds instead of actually entering the war
they explained their next target on the
payback team is going to be mindstorm
obviously he's a parody of professor x and the
x-men he just has low-level telepathic powers
they reveal mindstorm's go-to down is to basically
trap people inside their own nightmares it's like
doctor strange too multiverse of madness with
scarlet witch and professor x fighting inside her
mind because like professor x tries to go inside
her mind to save the scarlet witch from the 838
universe but mcu scarlet witch who's controlling
her mind basically attacks him too they used his
whole sequence during the episode to explain
butcher's backstory and why he's so terrible
in present day so don't worry i'll get to that too
because that was a huge part of the episode they
confirm all of our suspicions about maeve she is
still really alive but the global wellness retreat
that she was supposed to have gone to is basically
just a version of the bad room that homelander
referenced in earlier episodes they actually
featured this in some of the tie-in material
too this is basically the type of room where they
would put homelander when he was a child and he
was bad and they just had to discipline him but
because he's so powerful how do you discipline
someone who's that strong you put them inside
a nearly unbreakable room homelander makes some
references to it too like i'm going to have a son
someday who's too powerful to keep in here then
even though they have all these metaphors about
fathers children embryos artificial insemination
and it's meant to set at the end of the episode
with the big reveal of soldier boy and his true
father they reference him being bruised on his
face just to sort of set his ptsd arc and let
you know that he can be hurt by other characters i
think to set up more stuff with ryan later on like
they want you to think about butcher and huey and
soldier boy coming after him in this season but i
think that's a bit of a red herring like they're
probably not going to be able to kill him but the
idea is that he can be hurt he can theoretically
be killed eventually by someone and i think that
someone's going to wind up being ryan love the
way they treated this scene too when it goes from
really weird to really creepy homelander basically
tells her that they plan on eventually killing
her and just harvesting her eggs so that he can
have an even more powerful super baby with her
butcher then confirms that they understood soldier
boy's ptsd like they understand what's happening
and he's basically just trying to gloss over it
temporarily like just trying to treat the problem
with a band-aid so that they can accomplish
their short-term goal of killing home later
and somebody else can worry about it like it'll
be someone else's problem i think eventually it'll
wind up blowing up metaphorically and literally
in his face because that's kind of his power like
he blows up when he has ptsd it's also meant to
dovetail with the story line with the temporary
compound v causing their tumors and slowly killing
them like he doesn't want to deal with the problem
because he has the short term aspiration to kill
homelander like it's all worth it if we can just
get rid of homelander when it looks like they
might theoretically wind up killing themselves
just to get to the finish line even though i
do think they'll have a more hopeful ending
with huey's character loved all the black noir
scenes too just love the way they played this
like a really comedic kind of hallucination in
the tone of what happened with homelander in
last week's episode with him talking to the other
version of himself it's meant to kind of be the
same thing like these hallucinations that he sees
are basically the characters that are part of the
mythology of the restaurant the restaurant that he
goes to was a real restaurant when he was a little
kid that he just loved going to it looks like as
a young child he used these as coping mechanisms
like the same way that homelander always talked
to this other version of himself this is the
personality inside him it sounds like black
noir had his own version of that but with these
animated characters and this is just the way that
his mind depicted them when he was talking to them
we get the full backstory about why they got
rid of soldier boy in the past like all the
terrible things that he did he's way worse than
you thought that he was to the rest of the team
and if it wasn't clear the way the black
noir depicts all the team members they are
the characters that are from the mythology of the
restaurant so that's why all of his former payback
team members look like the restaurant characters
but i love the way he depicts himself as this very
gentle sheep just yelling about eddie murphy turns
out he was supposed to be in beverly hills cop
but soldier boy bad mouthed into don simpson who
was the real life producer of that movie the way
they explain it though that was much earlier in
the timeline it was a couple years after that that
they came up with a plan to actually get rid of
him they also confirm our theory that stan edgar
was the true mastermind of the plot to get rid
of him and it was mostly just because he was done
with him like stan edgar didn't hate soldier boy
he was just extraneous like they didn't need him
anymore they had someone better on the way that
they were going to create because of the whole
plot with homelander everything in that flashback
was meant to be them foreshadowing vogelbaum found
a way to create someone even more powerful who
can fly them setting up the reveal about them
using his genetic material to create homelander
they also confirmed that soldier boy was the
person who maimed black dewar's face so badly in
his throat so that he couldn't talk anymore but
like all these scenes where you see him talking
in the past it's the same voice of the actor who
you saw in the flashbacks coming back to voice
the character again the funny moment with stan
edgar refusing to stop eating the peanuts because
black noir is allergic it's just meant to show how
he doesn't care about any of the superheroes like
even though he's kind of helping them by getting
rid of soldier boy it's not because he likes them
or wants to help them it's just because soldier
boy has become more trouble than he's worth like
they're not making as much money off of him as
they could in present day stan edgar was trying to
do the same thing with all the current superheroes
like homelander because he'd found a better way
to make money selling the temporary compound v
to the military then mindstorm gets to drop on
them and you get all the butcher flashbacks him
getting trapped in his own nightmare and you
find out that yes their father was terrible
but because of all of his abuse it eventually
led to his younger brother killing himself and
butcher blames himself because he left to join the
military to get away from it but also explaining
that it was all of his father's abuse that caused
him to become a terrible person like his father
was terrible to him so he grew up terrible and now
he's kind of being terrible to ryan so the threat
is that he's going to let huey down in present day
like he let his brother down and he's also going
to let ryan down and eventually ryan will turn
into another homelander starlight finds out about
all the terrible side effects of the temporary
compound bee take it three to five times and is
basically a lethal dose like it'll turn your brain
into swiss cheese give you all kinds of tumors
basically it's like a death sentence so that
explains all the weird stuff that's been
happening to huey during the episode he also tells
butcher hey your brain's licking out your ear
and even though that was meant to be a joke in
the moment that could actually literally happen
to them if they continue taking the compound v
the whole idea that butcher doesn't tell him the
truth at the end like he wants him to keep taking
it because like i said he just wants to treat the
problem with a band-aid because he's more focused
on the short-term goal of killing homelander it's
just meant to be more of comic book butcher like
in the comics he's meant to be so bad he's so much
worse than the tv show version essentially he's
irredeemable that they might have a more hopeful
ending for the tv show version of the character
though the whole thing with starlight saying that
she's going to save huey's life whether he likes
it or not i think he's just meant to tell you
that huey will have a more hopeful ending like
he will survive this he's taken it about three
times even though she said that three to five is
lethal i believe butcher's taken at least once or
twice more than huey so i think the idea heading
into the finale they take it one more time it's
basically like the point of no return for butcher
they did confirm season four and butcher i believe
will come back for season four so i think whatever
winds up happening he will survive to season four
they have all these jokes about the deep just
being a super freak just kind of continuing
that storyline the joke about aquaman getting
it on with fishes but them doing it as a literal
thing on the boys is meant to be a parallel
for what stan edgar told the homelander like
well without me here to protect you from messing
up everyone will eventually see you mess up and
you'll just out yourself to the world for what
you really are it sounds like a version of that
is gonna happen to the deep like without his wife
there to tell him what to do he's gonna mess up
and just reveal himself to the world that really
messed up scene with soldier boy huey the priest
and the nun i think it just meant to flow with
the whole idea of his ptsd and just refusing to
acknowledge everything i think the idea is that
huey was meant to be correct the first time like
there wasn't anything weird going on with them and
the only reason the nun attacked him was to get
revenge for the death of the priest with all the
presidential campaigns and all the cameras on home
later i think they're just trying to set up the
idea that eventually soldier boy will be on stage
with homelander and something similar will happen
with him where like soldier boy will have a ptsd
episode and something crazy will happen a bunch
of people will die and it'll all happen on camera
i've already explained all the supernatural
easter eggs like this character here robert singer
the actor was on supernatural and robert singer
was also a real life person involved with the
supernatural show the showrunner of the boys was
also one of the other creators of the supernatural
show they had the whole subplot with victoria
newman just trying to use homelander to get more
power just willing to make all kinds of deals with
any person being just as terrible as homelander
she basically does the same thing with homelander
that she was trying to do with starlight and if it
wasn't clear the paper with the address that she
gave him was the address i think where soldier
boy huey and butcher were hiding out because her
whole thing was that she wanted him to take care
of the soldier boy problem so they could focus on
the presidency love the funny scene with the milk
too did you miss breakfast homelander taking his
kink straight to the source and speaking of milk
very cool mother's milk easter egg here when you
see him shaking up the milk here getting ready to
drink it in the comics mother's milk has compound
v powers and he gains super strength when he
literally drinks his mother's milk but on the tv
show this version of mother's milk isn't meant to
be a super or anything they also confirmed during
his storyline that frenchie figures out that they
can use nerve agent to temporarily disable soldier
boy so it sounds like they'll use that during the
finale they have the whole subplot with frenchie
and kimiko and her wanting to take the permanent
compound v again to get her superpowers but
they've kind of gone full circle with her
character like she's had like a full character
arc where she realized oh i can still be super
powered and not a terrible person all the terrible
stuff was just my personality before the fact
this is meant to show you that some of the
superheroes on the show can still have super
powers and not be terrible people but for the
most part most of them are supposed to be really
really terrible they do a bit of a cut too to the
subplot with a train to follow up with him but his
whole nightmare now that he's living with is that
now he's actually got blue hawks heart like he's
literally reminded of the person he hated so much
every time he does anything but if it wasn't clear
ashley wasn't lying they transplanted blue hawks
heart into a train so like his powers work fine he
can do whatever he wants to with his powers and
he doesn't have to worry about having episodes
then if it wasn't clear at the end of the episode
when soldier boy learns the truth from mindstorm
about what they did with his genetic material
creating homelander he did not tell butcher
or huey so like they don't know what's going on
homelander is the only other person that knows the
truth and like i said they play that whole scene
like a very darth vader luke skywalker star wars
type of twist like i am your father what father
wouldn't want that for his son so if you guess
the soldier boy and homelander we're gonna team
up you are correct pat yourself on the back but
remember next week's episode is the finale and
they haven't confirmed that soldier boy jensen
ackles is coming back for season four so something
really messed up is probably gonna happen to him
but i love the way they play this conversation
between them because when he reveals the truth
to homelander it's almost like homelander's brain
melts out of his ear like he has the blue screen
of death like somebody reboot homeland or you
broke him you broke his brain if you remember
he's been obsessed about this idea for his entire
life like he's always wanted a family he's always
wanted a father and he's having this huge
existential crisis because the person he's been
trying to kill this whole season winds up being
that father so i cannot wait to see the really
messed up way that they pay this off when the two
of them come together in the finale like i said
though there's this whole ptsd runner storyline
with soldier boy's character that is probably
going to metaphorically and literally blow up in
everyone's faces let me know in the comments if
you spotted any easter eggs in the episode that
i didn't talk about in the video in my full boys
episode 8 finale video we'll post next week after
it airs big reminder too thor love and thunder is
coming out in theaters next week too i'll be doing
a whole bunch of easter egg videos my review video
all that stuff we'll post next week after it comes
out everyone click here for my brand new dr doom
marvel video and click here for my brand new thor
love and thunder trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!